[Music]
life cannot be contemned life breaks
free life finds away
[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw
that time is for for kids who grow up
loving dinosaurs the Jurassic movies are
really the vehicle for them to see their
dreams realize the Jurassic movies have
always been suspenseful and exciting
we're telling the next chapter we're
literally blowing up the island
in this movie we have a new director
Juan Antonio Bayona I love playing with
suspense
I like intensity and I love to make the
audience feel the total experience he's
genius when it comes to frightening
people careful dinosaurs everywhere and
they're flipping out and killing people
let's go it was important to us that the
story be balanced on the characters some
of whom we know and some of whom were
just meeting Jeff Goldblum not gonna lie
that's pretty awesome
hi I'm talking about dinosaurs again in
this Jurassic world you will see more
dinosaurs than you've ever seen before
in this movie we are dealing with real
animatronic dinosaurs it looks like a
real dinosaur I couldn't help but freak
out the entire time the challenge of
making a sequel is finding the right
balance between what people aren't
expecting and what people will be
surprised by
[Music]
this movie is different it's going to be
intense and pretty spectacular
[Music]
that was my best acting
it's like nothing you've ever seen
before
man it's Jurassic
this is gonna be awesome life finds a
way so if you guys didn't know Malcolm
is coming back that's right jeff
goldblum came back for the sequel so the
movie is mostly about the dinosaurs
getting off the island and maybe
thematically this has always been the
case but they're making it more
prominent in the story in the newer
films making the dinosaurs the
protagonists and the humans the villains
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch of new stuff dropping because
we're getting ready for the holiday
season so there's a whole bunch more
trailers between now star wars in the
end of the year we don't know why the
volcano is active it might have
something to do with sabotage it might
be BD Wong's character Henry Wu trying
to work with the military to engineer a
scenario where they get the dinosaurs
off the island but they have to cause a
disaster in order to get people to go
rescue them or it could just be a
natural occurrence the whole thing in
the last movies that they were trying to
make hybrids the big new scary-looking
dinosaur that we see with the crocodile
looking jaws is the Baryonyx I think I'm
pronouncing that correctly but that's
sort of the new version of the indominus
rex but we don't know if this is a
hybrid of two other dinosaurs it could
be a Baryonyx mixed with the t-rex
because it looks much bigger than a
normal Baryonyx which is closer to human
size they brought blue back because she
was sort of the dancing baby Groot of
the first film
she might have hatchlings in this movie
and that might be the little blue
dinosaur that he's cuddling up to here
so this could be a flashback to baby
blue or it could be one of Blue's
children but you kind of see what
they're doing here they want you to
sympathize with the dinosaurs they want
you to want them to get off the island
but aside from BD Wong we don't know who
the villains are going to be in this
James Cromwell is starring in the movie
he typically plays villain characters or
characters that you think are good that
wind up being villains by the end of the
movie the disaster from the last movie
was so big it would make sense that the
government would get involved and it
would require such a large amount of
resources that they'd have to help out
in some way you can kind of see what
they're doing with the title to fallen
Kingdom as in the kingdom of the island
the actual park is falling because of
the volcano exploding then Malcolm has
that line in the trailer of
the dinosaurs outliving us as in our
fallen kingdom the rest of the world so
when they titled the first movie in this
new franchise Jurassic world I always
had the idea that they would eventually
spread out into the rest of the world
there has to be some sort of compromise
with the world's governments where they
allow dinosaurs to live in certain
places you can only imagine logistically
how they'd handle that but you have to
have sanctuaries for the dinosaurs just
like you have sanctuaries for endangered
animals but let me know what you guys
think of all this craziness the first
movie did gangbusters so I guess we'll
see how it does but what will happen is
is I have a new arrow midseason finale
video to post next there's some Justice
League DC EU that we have to talk about
because they're completely restructuring
their corporate department so the people
that actually make the DC movies at
Warner Brothers are changing along with
Ben Affleck maybe leaving the Batman
role after the flashpoint movie which
implies some plot points so I'll talk
about that in the video tomorrow but
just leave all your requests in the
comments below you can click here for
brand new Star Wars the last Jedi and
you can click here for brand new
Deadpool thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you